Hi, YouTube. I'm in Davos and the convention
of wisdom here is that to cope with the financial
crisis we have to restore confidence. And
I think that in order to restore confidence
it is-it is about leadership-political leadership
and business leadership. It is about the bankers
and business leaders who have been involved
in the financial crisis to just simply take
responsibility and say that mistakes have
been done even in good faith.
It is for politicians not to be taking by
temptation shortcuts or easy measures that
will be that are going to be unsustainable
in the long term like excessive spending-public
spending or protectionist measures.
Without this kind of leadership I think there
is a risk that forces of populism or extreme
west or-um-no-left or right ideologies could
further disharmonize our demo-democracy, and-and
even delay the solutions and implementations
of the measures that will need to be taken.
Thank you very much.